Runk
hello
hello not just saging waving my fling
all right so here's the deal we are it
is
lifeline and this is we are kicking
things off in the new year uh so join
our patreon do join our patreon at
Lifeline luxury patreon.com Lifeline
luxury join us and be a part of it 2024
is going to be amazing for Lifeline
luxury and it's just us messing around
having a good time no submissions just
Brotherly Love uh bant bant s in it um
you can uh get stream grow or die at
crystalia my new special I will also be
in Sacramento I added a second show
there Sacramento January 13th I'll be in
Brea California Phoenix Arizona El Paso
Texas Albuquerque New Mexico and a bunch
of other dates go to Chrystal lea.com
thank you very much uh I'm on tour so
get those tickets chris.com
yay yay uh submit yourself as a
potential guest to my upcoming podcast
the private record but guess what that's
coming out late even better
news that is being released the private
record is coming out January 24th first
drops bing bing bing set your Bing Bong
alarms because January 24th the private
record is released into the world if you
want to submit yourself as a potential
guest go to the private record.com
follow us on Instagram and Tik Tok at
theprivate record go to youtube.com/
theprivate record subscribe don't miss
an episode or a clip micro machine guy
you want to uh you want to uh you want a
private one-onone session guess what you
can do that mata.com book your boy uh
mata.com I'll give you the best advice
you ever received in your life and you
will want to thank me and kiss me and
hug me that's great always trying to cut
me off early why answer me now I don't
know I don't try to do that to you when
you're saying Phoenix I know in Atlanta
I know and I Tred to and frankly I said
it so fast I know you do so why do you
do
that talk to your therapist talk to your
therapist about it because I think it's
funny but it's not that funny so we live
we live and we learn you know we do uh
if you have a question some some kind of
advice you're seeking for this show you
want to be on this show click the link
in the description below or just go to
watch lifeline.com you know what I think
I like and I was actually thinking about
this I'm reading this magic M thing that
I drink and it says subtly sweet on
there and I like that I don't like
overly sweet as as I think that happens
naturally as we get older like Dad dude
how weird is this Dad what I mean when
we were kids I don't know if you
remember but we would drink Coke and dad
would say can I have can I have your
Coke for a second he would take it Pour
one like just a little bit into his
water yeah and I be like that what you
doing you're now you're you have two
things that are good water and Coke you
just made one thing that tastes like ass
but by the
way on purpose and now you're only
drinking the one thing but by the way he
would only do that like in my memory
like twice a year yeah no never but he
just I actually just did it like a
couple months ago and I was like you
still do that Maniac really yeah wow
yeah I I don't well I don't really know
that or or or like I don't think I'd
know that very well except for now that
I have kids like well Calvin because
he's almost four not not not Billy yet
but because he just doesn't eat really
anything yet but umh Calvin is
like I mean when candy comes around he's
like like I don't remember being like
that oh I'm sure we both were sure I
mean most kids are right that I guess so
but I'm it's it's like dude he loves
candy like he
says uh I don't like food I only like
candy oh and it's hilarious but he'll
like I don't know he he he uh he loves
chocolate and he he actually asked me
he's like can I not eat food can I just
eat like chocolate oh dude you know what
I just remember you know about me
legendarily in the family yeah we were
on vacation once as a family in Long
Beach Island when we lived in New Jersey
and Long Beach Island and I mean so
Jersey to say to be to even like have
that near you Long Beach Island Long
Beach Island that's but I only l
i I only I refused to eat real food for
I don't even know how long like a few
days at least maybe a week you probably
did eat something that's what I always
mom said mom was like no I asked her
that but Mom watch it well we all
exaggerate in our family and so does Mom
anyway I don't remember so I have to
rely on her memory she says all I ate
was those candy Smarties
and one day like just out of the blue I
started screaming for my mom from the
bathroom and she ran in and I was like
terrified because in the toilet there
was just like a purple log of dud dauki
in there from my R Reus Maximus and it
was just bright purple well okay I have
a memory that now this can't be right I
just I must have made it up that that we
have video recording of it we don't
though you know how dad had his big oh I
don't think so yeah yeah he was just
like K Cal news okay everybody get in
the frame what are you guys
doing um anyway yeah uh so it
couldn't like do you believe the poop
was purple I do and here's why when I
was 12 I was obsessed with those candies
gushers even at that age I love love
love the electric blue ones which is
don't eat don't eat anything you know
what you did love gushers and here's
here's the Here's the the repercussions
of loving gushers I gushed out of my
butt electric blue poop after I had like
three packs in one day and I was older I
had no excuse you with the electric blue
poops the electric poops I want to rock
down to Electric poop Avenue um when's
the last time you guys had like Frosted
Flakes wor
cist um I mean I don't so long ago I
really own only eat now like ice cream
yeah and then it's always way too late
at night for sweet I don't not eat
sweets like I I I do I I feel like I eat
healthy up until like 11: that's so bad
me too though I know but it's just it's
so bro it is so nice to sit down grab a
tub of ice cream and turn on
some [__] you know what I
agree it's just it's it's unfair it's
like come on Jesus I wanted it's
unbelievable dude there are days where
it's like 5:00 p.m. and I'm doing
something work in or whatever uh and I'm
like why can't it be 10:30 yet yeah so I
can go get the ice cream right it's like
I I want the ice cream the same amount
but at 500 p.m. I'm like I eat ice cream
now no it's not yeah dude you know what
dude I a few nights
ago was like like maybe I'll go to bed
early because I want to get a lot of
sleep and I knew I had to get up at
whatever
time and I was sitting on the couch and
I was like do I really want to do that
and I had this moment that lasted like
30 seconds where I was like man I so
don't want to do that because wow if I
stay up it's G to be so fun and if I go
to sleep early M tomorrow I got to wake
up and wait so long for the next day to
be over to be chilling with ice cream
yes and thing that's [__] on and I
had and it was like such a real feeling
it wasn't just like a thought it was
like my whole body felt it and I and and
I thought this is going to suck if I go
to bed early right yeah yeah like those
are the you know I I have a similar
thing where I'm so by far the most
anxiety free by far by far L what's that
what is that
it's um I can't remember his name uh we
called him I can't remember what it was
but when I went back to New Jersey um
like for the first time in a long time
and I saw all my old friends there was
another oh Frills oh that guy Frills the
guy that went by the nickname Frills
yeah Frills and he was I was like what's
your name he's like Frills I was like
what he's like frills frills he's like
yeah like for reals Frills that's a
great name yeah and by the way I was I
don't know how old I was at this point
16 no yeah yeah you were like yeah yeah
and uh and and I would say and I would
say every time I would say something he
would agree with he'd be like by far by
far by far oh I love that dude that's
really good it so makes no sense by far
by far oh that's how have I that's a
good one damn all right so anyway go
ahead doing that now I don't I have no
recol of what I was saying I'm sorry I'm
the most anxiety free late so even when
I'm like eyelids are so heavy at like
9:30 10 some days if I get up really and
I got a lot to do that day I'm so just
zoned but I'm like but but then if I
don't get to the part of the day that I
enjoy it'll be morning and I'll have not
enjoyed part of the day in so long yes
it is that dude why what happened to us
that that's something well I think it's
I think it makes sense maybe it's not
tell me if it's the same for you but
because the days yeah exactly you don't
how to do it you have responsib are so
stressful and full of exactly
responsibilities by the end nobody's got
anything to do nobody's gonna email you
about this or that nobody's gonna call
you with this problem you could chill
wow life is good though huh like you
don't have
to at late at night or just in general
no just in general like life is
sometimes good yeah you know sometimes
but some days it's awesome and then you
wake up the next day and you're like I
didn't know it wasn't going to be this
it wasn't going to be awesome how about
some days you wake up and you're just
dizzy yeah dude I had to happen that is
the
worst
Tuesday was that yesterday yeah I had
that yesterday yeah yeah yeah it's
terrible up until I went to the Lakers
game it feels like your eyes are trying
to go crossed all the time yeah it sucks
oh dude hey doctors hey doctors fix that
no we're the doctors we have a podcast
we're the doctors and we're talking
about ailments and we're and we're
exposing things diagnosticians that's
what we are okay the worst podcast name
diagnosticians nobody would know what it
means um that's what we did we named it
now other doctors need to cure it thank
you all the doctors that watch this show
thank you wow is there anyone who says
thank you that's not a [__] like a
[__] at heart you mean yeah uhhuh like
in their heart thank you like there
isn't anybody and I don't mean [__]
female any male or female it doesn't
matter I know what you mean you don't
mean like a mean woman you mean like a
[__] yeah yeah yeah dude I saw there
was a guy at the Laker game last night
that was like they would they do the
dance cam you know by the way I made it
on the Jumbotron hey all right it was
mostly about the women I were with you
know because they were dancing doing so
you didn't really make it they the
Jumbotron guys legit especially at the
Lakers game I don't know but they try to
get the hottest women on her of course
you would too I would too I guess and
kids right yeah kids too but but it's so
funny dude it's so cute when the kids
get on and they're so happy they're like
I'm on TV hey idiot you're not on TV but
it's so cute it's not that that cute no
I think it's cute cuz they think it's
such a big deal and it's like hey kid
nothing's a big deal you're going to die
soon all right it's cute but here's what
the overwhelming thing is this is what I
hate about
jumbotrons I get on the Jumbotron this
everybody on the Jumbotron
oh
mhm like you mean they don't know where
it is they don't know where the camera
is everybody and I don't like that um
what do you mean you expect everybody to
be like camera vers like oh there it
is but anyway um so we they got on the
Jumbotron they were dancing and then I
like a
[__] leaned in oh that's cool and I was
like and I I I because they were pretty
right and I lean and I go and I'm like
oh [__] we're in the Jumbo Tron yeah I
lean in I go oh God and I lean I don't
look good yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah well
not pasty white dude I need a tan go
outside but I don't do it go outside
it's so easy to go outside you have to
go outside for a long time though no you
don't not if you're as pale as you
you'll get a tan in like 15es sat in the
Sun the other day can you tell a little
20 minutes you don't you you don't look
as translucent as you usually do I don't
know if that's true anyway subscribe to
Lifeline luxury for more of us just
chatting but we're going to patreon.com
Lifeline lury if you don't sign up you
hate us the end that might be true a lot
of people who hate us wouldn't sign up
if you like us you will sign up so
that's the one I don't know if that's
gen 100% true but anyway right so let's
do uh a submission you can get a tanning
bed for
$33,000 well that's too much and no
don't do that but but also they're too
they're too big yeah where you going to
put it well well you know you have a
house you could put it somewhere but
like not really not in my house I mean
there's no place put in the studio
here well we already have an exercise
bike that takes up too much space and no
one uses gu's got an assault bike for no
reason you know it's got It's got a
bunch of [__] jackets on it I used it
earlier I lost I literally already in no
time I dropped 1.4 calories just like
that yeah that's not hard to do but it
not so hold on so
uh you shouldn't get a panning bed no of
course not just go outside that's weird
no one is thinking you should he just
said that they sell them they do sell
them yeah yeah I mean I was I was joking
he wasn't like suggesting know that but
I'm just saying people buy them for
their houses for sure yeah that makes no
sense no like
defitely have but why wouldn't you just
go outside because they it's like a flex
probably it's like oh got it also for
some
people w wow actually possessed for two
seconds there you think
it's ranks possessed by shab rank that's
what it is it's hard to get a tan right
now in
January okay not if you're me the UV
index has next episode watch watch me
next episode I will be so tan and I will
not have used a tanning bed it's just
like the movie that is my promise like
the movie
soulman I'm going to be really tan okay
imagine they made soulman today soulman
is just unbelievable that it ever got
made we'll talk about that on luxury
though okay I'll talk about let start
let's go yeah do you guys remember
taking down memory L it was a it was a
rainy
day also to Perfect Strangers when they
get two tan and balky and cousin Larry
no never mind of course not oh never
mind never mind of course not okay all
right all all right all right let's do
this submission come on Chrystal soet
since I started growing out my hair I've
been told that I look like Jesus but I
don't really know how to best respond
I've been doing things like going to
hell going to hell a higher power and
exerting it onto them well don't do that
that doesn't really get the crowd going
so looking for any kind of SP he's a
nurse you know all right here's the
thing about being told you look like
Jesus no I'll even let's go beforehand
cut your hair that'll help people stop
saying it also in general it looks wet
it look like a wet do it looks it looks
doesn't look good doesn't look good when
it's wet at least maybe when it's dry uh
so I've been told I look like
Jesus since I could grow facial hair
basically uh
and it doesn't matter at all so you
don't need to do anything about it okay
anybody that has some anybody that has
kind of long hair and kind of facial
hair there will be people that are that
say okay Jesus oh you got the Jesus look
going on it doesn't you don't do
anything you keep moving cuz it sucks
and when things suck that bad you just
keep moving you don't pay at no mind you
don't like come up with like a response
to it you act like it didn't happen
because you wish it didn't happen
because it sucked so bad so you want you
want to specifically not acknowledge
what they said so that they feel like oh
wait did he did he either not hear me or
does he actually dislike it that much he
doesn't want to hear it at all either
one of those ways you've won and so it's
a nonresponse that is key in this
scenario you're welcome just
say well dude just go like it's just as
Sac religious say go to hell
sacriligious can't do that go to hell
and then go like this or if they think
you are go like this cancer for you
that's good too touch their face cancer
for you lymphoma I mean so dark you know
a specific kind of cancer yeah yeah I
mean that's
just uh eat coli you're going to eat
dirty turkey
e so gross you know dirty just the two
words together dirty turkey it's good is
absolutely disgusting dude dirty man oh
wow now now you got to do that well I
just the guy you would get so mad at me
if I did that dude anytime I bring up
some kind of I know but then why do you
get mad at me I can explain it too but
you
don't got out of that
one no dude we had a friend well we have
a friend yeah but he used to live here
yeah uh and uh and he would
go man and he would say oh dirty
whenever something was cool right when
he thought something was cool he say
that's dirty man man
dirty God he was so funny huh that cloth
my brother's girls loed out
huh dude when he saw a pile of Chris's
old clothes that that Chris was going to
get rid of he looked at them and he said
what's up with that clothes I will never
forget it what's up with that clothes
and I was like what he was like that
clothes over there and I said
wait what are you talking about it's
those clothes he was like no that
clothes and I was like what do you mean
cuz they were in a I think he thought
cuz they were in a box you could just
single it out like it become singular
when they're all contained that's so
wrong that close he was so confused
though cuz he was like I think it's
wrong but also that close like like he
was it was 51% that close he thought
right you know right right and went with
it stripping uh all right so next
one nice C Ang hi Chris hi Matt hello um
first of all if you're seeing this thank
you for having me on the show I love
Lifeline so much I love you both so much
thank you love you too and I look
forward to the show every week so thank
you also to your producers Chris and
Anthony so thanks your parents who had
sex and made you so neighborhood am not
calling today to inquire for any
personal advice I actually that's thee
I've ever more light-hearted
thought-provoking question for the two
of
you because I just genuinely love the
banter B also curious just to hear your
thoughts and opinions said nothing so a
question that I often like to ask
friends just a general conversation
starter monolog mon is if you could have
a private dinner with one notable figure
Dead or Alive there we go who would it
be and why oh dude I am very curious to
see who you both pick and how that
conversation would go or what kind of
questions you would ask them she should
opportunity to have a private dinner
they' be like we um I'm curious to see
if it's like
histor figure or someone I mean yeah she
said famous orasan St so let me know um
I can't wait to hear say you're done and
if you like questions like this I can
definitely call in again because I have
plenty more where that came absolutely
well yeah we love it so we love it keep
calling in thanks so much love you both
it's okay you know nice nails nice nails
nice robe Rob nice Christmas nails
though she's so robed out she's so
chilling look at the soft blanket on her
W she's chilling thinnest tree ever
that's a branch she has a branch for
Christmas Branch tree is crazy dude um
hey dude this a tree this is a tree with
the ornaments on
it
look worst ornament Holy Night cover
your face doesn't want anybody to smell
your
[Laughter]
breath oh
all is high look oh I'm looking all
that's a tree no I love how he says look
and we're recording a show you know you
don't even say look at anything you're
being recorded and thousands and
thousands I know tens of thousands now
Calvin does it dude he says look yeah he
I mean you're [__] not only that he
goes like this oh that's just like
manipulates my that's so rude so it's so
funny dude well yeah now he goes like
this look look on TV look oh like buddy
what if he still did it when he's like
you know 28 all right so dead or
alive my my my kneejerk my my the one
that I would pick and have has been this
it's been this way for decades is
Tupac Jesus Christ you don't think that
that's good Jesus Christ Jes Christ you
don't think really you're that
shocked no I would pick Jesus Christ
or I kind of want to I I would love to
also Napoleon bro a villain as I was
gonna say like a um hit genas Kong oh
genas Kong but then communicating with
genas Kong you be like I know no the
salt pass the salt are you sure just
like no one cut off my head you know um
so it's implied obviously that there's a
translator there we could communicate
yeah adding I don't know French but uh
exactly well I don't know you know
Aramaic but I would like Jesus Christ I
I Think Jesus Christ Jesus spoke uh
English now he was white he says lit and
stuff and he spoke English hey hey ly
like a
titty what did you say litty like a
titty litty like a titty okay hey hey
hey YOLO hey you know what YOLO maybe he
did say
YOLO um but yeah no I uh I think I
think I don't know but off the top of my
head I'm pretty sure I would ultimately
be like I guess I got to pick Jesus
Christ I'm not even Christian understand
yeah yeah yeah yeah I got to know what
he what he was led to you know would
pick uh uh Tupac or Sebastian
Stan
or um the guy from sideways not Paul
Giamatti who's the other guy he played
Sidman y Thomas haen Church I'd have so
many questions about Sandman from
Spider-Man character that's he played
Sandman oh yeah he did uh yeah he played
Sandman yeah I guess I guess um [__]
yeah yeah okay Jesus or the kid from
Young Sheldon I mean get so many like
whatever actors a lot of living guys
yeah uh so what's it like being on young
what's like being what on young
Sheldon so what's it like being on young
Sheldon he's like 12 he's like I don't
but uh dude okay our producer just did
the craziest yeah he slayed a dragon
that was what that was him blowing his
nose sounded like an elephant being
mauled no it sounded like a one of the
like a like a like a clown with the like
did this thing yeah all right like it
said somebody you should have said Happy
New Year before it
um okay but so yeah that's what I would
pick or you know I would really like to
pick
like I would really like to pick Tupac
but you did pick Tupac I know I think I
would have to pick Tupac why is
Sebastian Stan I'm joking man hey anth
you know me you know me oh dude because
I really want to know about his how he
got into character and Winter
Soldier Anthony dude you knew he was
kidding I really didn't hey dude hey
dude oh my God that Hulu thing you did
what was it called so when you were in
Pam and Tommy what was that like
meanwhile I'm at the other table with
Jesus Christ yeah yeah yeah yeah Chris
is looking over like I wish I anon's
like this over leaning over to my
side why did he pick seban stand and
missing Miracles and [__]
Jes yeah that's a good question but yeah
Jesus Christ um Jesus Christ Jesus
Christ and Sebastian Stone are our two
answers Hitler would be a crazy one
that's I a villain would be a villain is
is more interesting in many because
you're not that way so like what you
would be like what you are very much
like Jesus right you want to also know
with someone like that it's like how yes
my main question about someone like how
did you get so many people on your side
you're so obviously terrible there's
something in there like what's going on
I would just want to see it so I could
be like okay imagine so confusing to me
you know with Hitler would be like
dinner with Hitler a play a two-handed
play Hank's area would be in it Hank his
area
and then would be play he would play
Hitler with like his one of his great
accents and and he would get nomin for
for a [__] Tony wow that's good Hank
iseria as Hitler
dude you know what's crazy about aaria
dude he's so yolked you ever seen his
isy [__] arms dude no no dude there's
a movie did with Jennifer Anderson where
he plays like a the sexy something guy
oh shirts off the whole time and you go
what the
[__] aaria dude he's got the be F him
he's got money too that's for sure oh
from The Simpsons oh yeah oh yeah uh he
got that Simpsons money did he do the up
poo voice he used to I mean what he that
is people there's a whole documentary
about how [__] up that stereotype was
yep well times change my friends times
change yeah who cares about any of it
you know yeah for sure so anyway let's
to next one hey guys want to take a
break and talk to you about DraftKings
an official betting partner of the NFL
playoffs is bringing you an offer
that'll help make make the playoffs
electrifying new customers can bet five
bucks on any game and get 200 instantly
in bonus bets 200 instantly in bonus
bets come on my favorite team even
though I have no affiliation whatsoever
is the Detroit Lions always has been
thank you Barry Sanders and they're my
team this year in the playoffs the
spread is three they're big favorites
but I'm still putting my money on them
if I'm making bets uh don't tell my
mommy download the DraftKings Sportsbook
app now and use code Lifeline new
customers can bet just five bucks to get
200 instantly in bonus bets only on
draftking Sportsbook with code Lifeline
the crown is yours gambling problem call
1 1800 Gambler or visit www.1 1800
gambler. net in New York call
8778 hopen or text heny 467 369 in
Connecticut help is available for
problem gambling call 8
8887895118
varies by jurisdiction void in Ontario
bonus bets
expire 168 hours after issuance C
dk.com
for eligibility and deposit restrictions
terms and responsible gaming resource
ources what's up Chris and Matt big fan
of the show get right to it that's a
hell of a muscle last night I was
hanging out with my buddy we were
drinking having a good time and then he
admits that the last time he was hanging
out with me and my girlfriend uh oh he
admits that he was flirting with her oh
and not only that but he says that
apparently she was flirting back with
him God which I don't believe at all cuz
I was there you know noticed I
think and I you know I asked him like
well what did you say what do you mean
mean like flirting he didn't tell me
what he said but he says that there was
an
implication and he was kind of coming to
me like almost like apologetically and I
was like oh yeah like don't worry about
it and I didn't know what to say so I
was just like I think sometimes when
guys and girls talk they only thing they
know how to do is flirt with each other
and I regret saying that because I don't
believe that at all he asking me how do
I be friends with a girl and not like
flirt and I was like uh I don't know
just act like she's one of the Bros and
or just
but like I don't know just don't flirt
with her not that hard so I want to
bring this up again but I don't want to
be a sadic about it so yeah what should
I say and what should I do this is a
great submission first things first
though how is the front of his hair the
exact same as the mustache what do you
mean look at the shape of the front of
his hair the top of it it is exactly the
same shape as his mustache pretty good I
wonder if his pubes are like that I they
just come down a little bit on side and
then nothing there's a nose over it um
yeah that that's weird bro your friend
sucks dude like why is this guy Mak he's
making it a problem and you don't even
give a [__] and you think it didn't
happen exactly you were there you didn't
think it you didn't see it your girl
probably thinks it didn't happen of
course so why is he he's just a little
mcshit starter this gu guy yeah yeah
he's trying to instigate he's an
instigator D Aiden mcshit starter this
guy from Ireland why that bothers me
dude Aiden um 82 remember no what is
that you don't oh ad do do you the
plumber dude yeah what do I do I can't
get my I don't know what to do I can't
get my ad do no I don't know that at all
all right um and I'm happy I don't well
no no trust me you'd be happy if you
knew what it was but anyway I will watch
I will watch into got into um so all
right uh bring it up just bring it up
dude like don't worry here's the thing
that guy broke so many unspoken rules
it's weird it's weird and some spoken
ones like that is just it's it's it
Teeters into like rudess you're just
making something out of nothing for no
reason hey dude I flirted with your girl
at all no you didn't yeah I did it was
weird yeah exactly that's what Happ
that's literally what happened and she
knows it and she flirted back that's
what happened that's literally what this
guy like you don't don't worry about
being a dick or not just like don't try
to be a dick but don't worry about it he
didn't worry about it you don't owe him
that in fact this guy's not probably not
a good friend like what is this guy
doing I'm trying to think about if I did
that so I'm trying to think about if I
flirted and knew I flirted with my
friend's girlfriend hold on
and yeah I would feel bad you feel bad
and not bring it up in the hopes that no
one noticed or agreed and I would then I
would not do it again and then you'd be
relieved right right right right you got
like you're like oh thank God nobody
notic I'm I'm never going to do it again
but but dude what a such a psycho unless
this guy's like a sober dude like a
super so some of those super sober dudes
are like I have to admit my shortcomings
like no matter what and sometimes those
people are like you're like dude you
know you don't have to I have to tell
you guys I I I left I left the I left
the gate open in my house and I'm I'm so
upset you're just like bro this is not
my problem shut the [__] up you know
boring um it's boring it is boring but
this in this case it's it's not boring
well no it's not that it's not boring
it's that it's you're affecting you're
making everything worse yeah you know so
yeah way worse I mean it wasn't bad at
all honestly laugh about it with your
girl laugh about it with your girl talk
to your girl about of course that but if
he wants to bring it up with him which
is his right then just what I'm saying
is bypass the thing in your brain that
is making you feel like it's going to
sound like you're a dick a you're not
gonna because you're just you're a good
guy you're not going to be a dick but B
don't like don't worry about it even if
you did sound like a dick it would
actually be somewhat warranted because
this guy [__] made a whole drama go
that far this guy made a whole drama out
of nothing yeah that's the that's a
thing that's a it's are you sure it's
this just sounds like something you know
what dude this is some sounds you know
what I already does this guy go like
this wait um wow didn't even know what
you ask I but I forgot what it was does
this guy go like uh what was the thing
we said that [__] do when [__]
early say thank you thank you yeah he's
a [__] right that's crazy that is that
is that is crazy he's a little [__]
starter dude that's what I'm saying dude
you're a little [__] starter man I don't
like [__] starters even though I one not
there's only room for no I'm not I'm not
like that no I know I like when two
people disagree I'm like oh I want them
to to tussle about it yeah yeah yeah you
want to work it out yeah but I like
seeing them argue and stuff really yeah
because I like to argue but like in good
fun I don't like when people actually
get upset you know yeah right I get it
at all but take a
Vanetta what are you said oh nice yeah
hey you know what joke I hate the most
is is this joke our mommy saw your
wallet recently I don't have any money
in it so sad my money but uh just robbed
you you know David
blae the the when you have your wallet
on the thing and and dude I hate don't
don't even say it I'm gonna get S piss
why people do this it's not funny I have
good friends that have done this to me
multiple times and I have already told
them it's
so boring and a waste time yes dude okay
so say it this is what it is
your W's on the table it's usually right
when you do it you put the wall on the
table you talk
you're oh that I mean that is even more
annoying than the thing I thought you
were what did you
think oh you pretending oh you're
pretending you're stilling my money give
it back say something like this you know
if you leave your wallet out there
somebody's going to swipe it if you're
not careful that that's well that's
annoying yeah but that's honestly
regular annoying that's like what are
you doing this is like you think you are
doing something they think they're
actually getting away with it no they
think it's funny they think it's they
want you to see it yeah no that's the
whole thing is that they go like this
they go like this or like or or it
happens a lot like look I got a new
wallet oh let me see oh let me see oh
cool let me see let see and they take
the money out and they're like I would
do that I would do that one that's not
funny I didn't do it though right now so
maybe I wouldn't do it truth comes
out it's not it I guess there's a way to
do it funny but my god
dude it's one of the things that I can't
stand the most and it happens too much I
got to be honest I don't think that has
ever happened to me it will you're
unfortunate it's unfortunate it's
happened to you so many times it'll
happen to you now that you said it it
will just like that guy get new
friends I got one friend and you know
who you are dude nice so many so many
people are like it's Dan that's me until
you said it's Dan okay
next hi Chris and Matt oh my God we've
SE from Scotland guy with the beard that
was asking for advice the guy with the
beard so one of the things I totally
blanked on was the fact that I should
have said when I asked for advice on my
beard whether I should keep it or not I
actually have a really big corporate job
believe it or not fuing this I've got
like hand tattoos and all that mental
but since hearing back from you guys I
don't know if it's I hold
myself two things oh uh number one is
what did he called about originally
number two what is he saying I
think I mean the F the first thing he
called about was asking if he should
shave his beard or not right right oh
cuz he got a and now he's saying because
he has a corporate job and he left out
the fact that he got a corporate job
right is that what he's saying yeah he's
got the tattoos and he already got he
already got the job well let him finish
all right let me finish let me finish
let me finish what is that South Park oh
okay
cool hit play
whatever but I have been given a
confidence boost it's something I do
lack in and I just wanted to say thanks
for that I was walking onto a flight the
other day business class
and the air stward who was
straight surprise was like
um wow this is you you look so well
presented so I straight my beard and had
like a shirt in that one and uh and and
you know it's so nice to get me
compliments now and
then but here it's also much nicer to
have a bit of confidence and I just
wanted to say thanks to you guys so it's
not all don't you but mostly me cheers
hell yeah what did we do we gave him
compliment you said before you said his
beard was nice and he should keep it
yeah right yeah so why are you acting
confused man this isn't
English it's English it's talking in
rewind I mean I know it's going to be
annoying to you but it's more English
than how we talk that's not annoying to
me okay cool that is not annoying to me
uh but yeah no I actually maybe
surprisingly fully understood what
you're saying yeah okay I here's what I
understood he had we he has a beard that
that we liked we talked about it I I
vaguely remember I do remember yeah he
was like should I shave it yeah should I
yeah right we said no cuz we love it
it's a great it is a great beard right I
mean a beard that looks like an upside
down broom is killer that is a truly
great I mean you turn you spin his head
around and you put a red ball in the
middle of his face he's Beaker okay and
he's what Beaker from The Muppets and I
what the [__] I I think that he um looks
great and so what he's saying so what he
send us now is he's sending a video
saying thank you thank you and it made
me feel confident and now I have
confidence and in my corporate job I
don't feel like weird because I have it
but on top of that he was on a flight
recently right I heard that and a
straight male flight attendant don't
know why specifically all right because
because for some reason if the more
higher you up in the atmosphere the more
you want to [__] guys oh is that true I
don't apparently every Steward is every
male Steward is like gay as [__] I don't
what is it about being near the clouds I
don't think that's it but yeah well okay
you think they're straight when they're
on the ground and they get up further up
I think the more time you spend the more
time you spend it's a good call back but
more it's great it's great I was already
talking I I already talking no but um
the more time you spend up above 30,000
ft then yes you start thinking hm wonder
what it's like in a guy's butt okay and
the rest of what he thought was saying
was that guy that flight
attendant uh complimented him on his
beard yeah and what he said is that's
really nice as a little confidence
booster but nothing's nicer than no no
nothing nothing that was really nice to
hear and it made him feel good but
there's nothing better there's no
replacement for conf confidence that you
also think it looks good and that's why
he's thinking Us in particular I I I
pretty much got that okay good I thought
that's what it was great um so I wonder
if he sounds as difficult to understand
if we sound as difficult to understand
to him as he does to I wonder do
probably not because the American accent
is so like more ubiquitous like all
Place U ubiquitous and omnipresent if
you want to add another word like that
oh wow um just adding huh you know cool
any other words you want to add that
mean the same thing Bas all around
everywhere nice um but I I I do think
that
um guy seems like a really nice guy he's
very nice yeah yeah really nice guy and
a great beard great beard and if you got
the job at with the beard and Tattoos
you don't need to do anything no he's
not goingon to yeah also I think the
time for like if I had a doctor come in
with tattoos on his like neck I would I
wouldn't I don't I wouldn't think twice
about it would
you what kind of doctor are we talking
about honestly a
surgeon what's the
tattoo you're right I failed out a med
school no um it [__] the world yeah
right well of I yeah if it's [__] the
world you don't trust them with anything
correct yeah it's just Mo you know
across money over [__] um yeah I
guess it would give me pause if if the
doctor that was going to cut me open had
was yaded up that's probably stupid
honestly cuz as you're pointing out yeah
so many people have tattoos all over
their body mean anything you know what I
might think is oh you know what's
interesting is I don't feel weird that
he has a lot of tattoos and probably 20
years ago it would have been insane
that's what I might think yeah well you
also have tattoos all over you so it
makes sense that you wouldn't think
anything I guess so but I got them way
late so I don't know maybe maybe not
maybe not okay yeah if it was just like
it might I would I would be like oh wow
that's so weird my doctor's yeah I would
definitely clock it but I would think it
was like oh wow this is cool but then
again I I have tattoos trying to hang
out with them afterwards what are you
doing what are you
doing you busy after
this stop talking please stop talking
God damn it all right next get me the
paddles oh my oh yeah hey so what you
doing later still when he comes back
okay start it
over the joke no hello Chris hello Matt
uh just want to start off by saying I
love you both so much Chris I saw you in
October um in Hamilton and today I just
bought the VIP package for me and my mom
who are huge fans and so excited to meet
you um Chris I don't know bring Matt
with you because maybe we can go on a
little date after but um my question for
you today is I lost about 70 lbs since
last year may till now 70 huge
difference I was almost close to 200 lb
shed a lot of weight worked really hard
um a lot of people feel the need to
comment it's fine and for the most part
I'm like okay whatever like that's okay
um got a lot to say but you know when
people are commenting on my specific
dietary restrictions and you know oh
things that I eat and the need to work
out often uh they're haters I don't know
how to deal with it it kind of gets to
me sometimes
I really let it affect me and uh I get
really angry I'm like why I don't want
to be angry I want to be happy you know
but it's just mean things that are just
like you're too skinny uh you need some
more weight you look better things like
that and it's just not appropriate cuz
when I was a little bit chubbier no one
felt the need to say that I needed to
lose
weight feel the need to say about me
being th and healthier and happier I
don't think it's appropriate but is
there any spin move mentality um
anything that you guys would recommend
I'd greatly appreciate it it's been
hardk you what I think you could
probably speak to her better than me but
I because you're fatter than me but no
but for real the one thing I want to say
before we even give any advice I think
the the anger thing I couldn't relate
more when you say I'm it makes me angry
but I don't want to be angry I want to
be happy I promise you you will be angry
for less time if you let yourself be
angry instead of trying to not be angry
it will minimize the amount of time at
least not the amount of anger but it
will get you through to the other side
of the anger quicker if you're like I'm
mad and that's okay I'm going to be mad
and then that'll be you know that'll end
sooner than if you're like no I'm not
mad nope no no not mad I want to be
happy it'll just bleed out into long a
longer period of time go ahead I what
did she say about the thing that was a
good point that she said that I missed
it she said everybody's trying to tell
me I should put on some weight should
put on some weight but it's but what's
interesting is that when I I was heavier
no one was telling me I should lose some
weight what that is that is she's right
that that is so inconsistent like if
she's too heavy why aren't if she was
too heavy why aren't the same people
that are saying now put you should put
on some weight why weren't they saying
you should lose some weight they ha if
it's I know but her point is good she
saying if these people are consistent
really worried about my health CU they
don't care about you exactly I mean they
might care about you but they don't not
in that moment they're they're being
dude most people in the country
certainly I don't know about the world
but definitely this country would love
to lose 70 lbs dude most people in this
country actually over 50% are overweight
she's in a different country but yeah
she is she's said Canada I think that's
doesn't count that's that's still
American um
but I got off here I got off stage the
other day and another comedian said hey
that was a great set and I actually
thought I must have not done well ah I
swear to God that was the first thought
I had you mean is that how much
comedians are it's just people but like
I was like I bet they wouldn't have said
I did great if I [__] obviously did
great weird yeah that that that says a
lot about me too but also I I just think
that
um I I I think people just they
don't they feel so comfortable when they
look at you and think there's something
wrong with you you know they they people
feel uncomfortable about
hanging out with beautiful people
because they're not that it makes them
insecure and you're more beautiful when
you're not two [__] 300 lb whatever
but don't you think that has something
specifically to do with the fact that
they know she lost the weight what that
requires what the kind of willpower the
kind of planning the kind of mental
fortitude it requires to be able to do
that don't you think that whether they
realize it or not these people are
taking into that into account when they
say what they say like yeah even more
it's not just that she looks great now
and some stranger comes up and no one
that doesn't know her would say that
only someone that knows how hard she
worked and how much weight she lost
would say oh you know what you're too
skinny now you should put on some weight
yeah that there in lies something worth
thinking about as well like people who
know you it's they have all these
feelings that are just backloaded in
their own [__] minds that's their
[__] problem now yeah when they come
out you with that [__] all you should be
hearing like think about like subtitles
under what they're saying and those
subtitles say I hate myself this has
nothing to do with you honestly when
people say [__] like that just picture
words underneath their face saying I
hate myself I I don't and that's it yeah
it's just I know it's you so it's a
little convoluted I guess but it's so
obvious from here that people are doing
that because just straight up that
Middle School jealousy [__] and it's and
it's unfort because and here's why it
makes you mad here's why it makes you
[__] mad one of the reasons is
because you worked so hard for this and
they're these [__] lazy [__] that
aren't doing the work won't do the work
and you think you got the audacity to
just be like you should eat more [__]
this makes me feel great yeah right I
look great I I feel great and you're not
going to take that from me you lazy
failure but also the reason you know
these people are so full of [__] is that
something that she said the thing that
she said about other people like when
she or rather when she was heavier no
one was suggesting she lose weight
because people are comfortable with
other people not being feeling looking
their
best you didn't say what I'm saying I
said PE I I said a version of
that oh okay then I'll just shut up no
no don't shut up just saying you just
shut me up because you're like I already
[__] said that why would what the
[__] do you mean you didn't say that I
all I said a version of it but it's not
worth getting as angry as your no it's
[__] annoying to be like I already
said that when you
didn't nice to meet you you've been
around I said a version of you didn't
know that you didn't know that okay I'm
glad I I I'm glad I let you know Welcome
To Earth uh but yeah dude to
say welcome to Earth is the most dick
[__] anyway no I actually did not hear
said that once I've said it
already uh but yeah dude we're both we
are both saying the same general [__]
which is like [__] all of those people
but the truth is I think you know that
and I think what really is making you
mad is that these people are supposed to
be your support system they know you
they're supposed to love you and think
of you or treat you better than that and
I agree they should but it's a sad case
that people are not like that the
saddest part about all this is that
these people don't realize
they're being shitty not only that they
don't realize that they have these
feelings that are making them say these
things in the [__] first place dude
they think if you were to ask them they
actually would say well no I'm just
looking out for right should add some
weight and that's [__] and that's
one of the hardest things about being an
adult human these people there are
people in our lives that genuinely love
us that say things to us that cause us
pain that they don't even realize
they're doing it on purpose to cause us
pain that is so [__] up I know but
that is one thing we just have to deal
with you know you're right though and
you know you're on the right path and
the way you know this is because you
feel better and you look better your
confidence is higher all these things
you already know deep inside you you
don't need these other people to tell
you this you already know it I get why
it makes you mad but again this is just
one of those things we have to live with
it's how people are doesn't mean they
love you less doesn't mean they want to
hurt your feelings like if they really
checked themselves and thought wait do I
really want to hurt this person of
course they don't this is how [__]
people are it sucks they're all twisted
up they are everybody's all twisted up
dud one time I said
I was man this was so long ago but I was
I invited a a girl out to my
show and you know she's pretty and all
that and we were and then later
on she said something
like oh I I I can't remember something
was like either she had a boyfriend or
like and I was like oh well why did you
come you know I invited you to the show
it was just her showed up and
and she said oh I I can't remember what
she said but I ended up saying like hey
this is this is Earth and I I remember
saying that because Joe Rogan laughed so
hard name nameing
bragging triple layer bragging you know
so I said that first too anyway wow oh
yeah so quadruple level yeah no I'm
joking but it made me think of that and
that's why I was thinking the whole lot
so anyway I a lot of crazy people that
one time Paul M was show so anyway um
was
he yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm pretty
sure he liked Jim Jeff better
but Jeff who je Jim Jeff was also on
Jeff yeah he would like Jim Jeff yeah
yeah yeah for sure God Paul McCartney
dude Paul McCartney could he look more
like an old lesbian no okay what are we
doing next dude how much does Paul
McCartney think a gallon of milk cost
$45 why because he just has no idea oh
he's like so out of touch yeah no he
thinks it costs a nickel cuz that's what
it was when he was a kid you know yeah
no yeah but going to talk to me about
going to pull meide pull me aside after
the show wa you said about thing in the
milk going text me uh all
right what's up Matt and Chris long time
listener first time submission oh yeah
video uh wearing a jacket inside it's
very cold insecure anyways I have a work
situation I'm going to be a nurse and
currently I work as a caregiver in an
old folks home and we clean people up
we're dealing with poop you're doing a
lot of anus stuff then you name it um
good man the caregiving staff Works
close with the housekeeping staff and
the head housekeeper uh has really had
it out for me uh ever since I first
started working there but recently uh
it's gotten kind of aggressive like I
got over that she would never say hi
back to me that's fine but that's so
weird though uh without going into
further detail it's starting to get
Beyond passive aggressive like it's
starting to get aggressive and uh I've
had this idea to go to the kitchen with
a glove on cuz we always wear gloves at
work and put chocolate sauce and maybe
some caramel sauce in my hand and uh she
has lunch at 11 so I was thinking of
putting my hand on the door handle of
her door you know pretending that it's
poop oh so when she comes back from her
lunch and she opens her door she'll get
chocolate and caramel sauce on her hand
which is no big deal but she's going to
think it's poop is this too far I don't
think it is maybe I'll microwave a
Snickers bar and just smear it on her
door if it gets worse but what would you
guys do if uh you just can't win someone
over and it's getting progressively
worse and worse appreciate you guys I
would not do anything and start ignoring
that person as well I was going to
suggest though you you're you're in a
perfect situation to just [__] on her
desk and be like oh I don't know who it
was there's that possibility as well he
was doing the fake route with the
chocolate sauce I was just here's here's
what I find suspect and I think you
might agree with me he didn't say the
things she does yeah except for so I
don't think she's I don't how bad could
it be well no but he said without going
into further detail which means there is
further detail which of course which
could also mean isn't but it we don't
know and and if there is something I
understand the reason why he wouldn't
want to say it is because he doesn't
want I mean I know he's Al he's also
like submitting it on here so people
will see it but he doesn't want to
expose anything okay fair enough you're
right I usually usually the one doing
what I'm doing is you and I'm arguing
take him at his word so fine let's take
him at his word I still think you
shouldn't do the poop thing like we're
not 8 years old it's pretty funny if
this if this person is
like a dict to you and doesn't say hi
back stop saying hi to her stop engaging
with her Let It Go or say hey what
what's what is going on like this is
getting so weird right now like what do
you not realize what's happening I think
you do like what and then just ask yeah
yeah right I mean why would you start
with a vicious backand it's a little
trickier she's I think she's his um oh
Superior yeah oh I I didn't get that but
because it's she's the head of a
different part though uhhuh yeah maybe
not but um so maybe not but yeah I I if
she is a superior then I get why you
wouldn't the person I didn't get if she
is a superior then maybe do the the [__]
don't yeah maybe lean towards the [__]
thing then after all no but I still
think under no circumstances are we
going to do the [__] thing okay let's
just
yeah it's probably not the best idea
yeah if you want to get her that's not
the right
way you know yeah poison or food yeah
poison or food no don't do that um of
course not obviously I I don't I don't
know what to do I think who I think I
actually think and this is
not it's not really advice but I here's
what I think who cares who cares that's
what I'm trying to say yeah you know I
think you're supposed to not care about
this you wait expound on that though
like well you you just have someone
that's not being nice to you that isn't
really somebody you care about exactly
though that's kind of what I'm trying to
say so it doesn't matter and realize
that realize it doesn't matter at all
use
realization it doesn't matter so use
your realization skills what I would
what I would ask this guy though
hopefully you're watching why do you
care so much
like does it Bo hold on but does it just
bother you so much when people are
passive aggressive or roote to you in a
like is that what's up like what's going
on with you that it bothers you so much
because honestly I think most people
would just be like oh that person is
such a dick I'm going to stop engaging
with her right that's what most would do
oh yeah so maybe but again maybe the
thing he didn't want to mention the
details of was actually some kind of
aggressive act that like we don't not to
who knows what her side of the story is
too right what I always say but I mean
like right you
know is she he said it was from the
start though this woman was yeah like a
like a like a like a like she was one of
the bad guys in Rebel Moon the [__]
movie like I dude that I cannot believe
they still make movies you talked about
this I can't believe they still make
movies with with guys the antagonists
who are just dicks from the beginning
like it's an Eric Roberts movie in 1990
well I mean a gen genely love Eric
Roberts movies from around 1990 but
that's because of the tone and the the
time period also there was a period of
time where he was such a good actor yeah
sure no but I'm just I I understand what
you're saying but also we have literally
talked about this I think it might have
been last week yeah on this what yeah
you talked about villains from older
movies but still in movies I don't like
him like that guy like dude how can
there be a
movie now that comes out where there's
just a guy being a dick not liking
one or two of the characters for no
reason it that's the worst Trope it's
just laziness yeah it's so lazy but how
do you not be be a
[__] I guess they just don't care but
but filmakers do care they care about
some stuff right only really good
filmmakers care about all of the stuff a
lot of filmmakers now or or for always
have just been like well that's just I
want to get that part out of the way I
don't care why he's a dick he just needs
hate him you know right right right um
yeah God that movie is so bad Rubble
Moon yeah I didn't even know it until
you brought it up yeah I mean there's
nobody that's more completely off my
radar as a filmmaker than Zack Snider I
know I didn't dude I didn't even know it
was Zack Snyder I I was talking about
how bad it was on my podcast and then
afterwards I looked it up and I and I
said Zach like a [__] course now
people are going to think I [__]
trashing it because me the dead I
actually totally forgot about that but
yeah um yeah I don't know Man
movies CGI and [__] like it's it looks
worse and worse I don't understand what
happened there was a period where it
just started to yeah they know people
watch it anyway budgetary thing probably
yeah but I don't know that I don't know
if that's the answer but
that's uh cuz some people do the
craziest coolest [__] with no money I
know I still want to see that Godzilla
minus one movie but oh I don't know I
guess it's CGI but like yeah there's a
lot of it's $15 million they made that
movie for yeah well that's the thing if
you're really good like that that
District 9 asre with math so they
probably figure out where to put the
money sry RAC but there's a there's a
you know that guy Neil Blom Camp right
yeah yeah he made n for like nothing he
does huge movies now what's that new
movie he did I just watched did he do a
new one oh no the short films on Netflix
right he did Gran Turismo actually I
said the short films on Netflix I don't
know Neil Blom Camp did Gran Turismo are
you kidding me that movie is [__]
trash what what is he doing dude is he
was so interesting have you seen it no I
know it's not interesting look at the
[__] the guys in it from uh he so oh
my God he's so good though elisium was
good chappie that's funny cha I saw
chappie yeah he's good with that [__] he
really is but but when there's not any
of it yeah exactly he also did uh
elisium I I just said lum's good am I
dick for bringing that back up again I
said
so he did a show on Netflix that was
like
um uh that's what I yeah what was that
called uh was one word demonic no no no
it's no it's it's newer it's a show
though is this movies oh oh oh he's
[__] it up Anthony's [__] it up
yeah he's [__] it up big time right
maybe you know what he maybe only
produced it to be honest a so maybe
anthon he didn't [__] it up he probably
directed The Pilot though at least yeah
so he [__] it up you know what I'll do
I'll do it quicker than him is what I'll
do yeah do do do it on your phone and
get it quicker than Anthony Lima no lost
his mind just saying well you know what
lima lima might be one of the things in
the collection click
Lima click
it what is
it what the [__] Anthony doesn't know
how to do anything soury Weaver's in it
that's all I know or wait no not soury
Weaver God damn it I don't know who's in
it soury Weaver's in it oats Studios yes
that's what it is oats Studios why would
that be the name of anything [__]
final man oats Studios WL for brimley's
in it so stupid then he do the quick
arose thing yeah know what I heard about
wiford Brimley the biggest dick in the
world the biggest dick in the world
apparently ismy I was going to say that
him and but also the guy from CSI
Wilford dickley Willi Peterson no CSI
the [__] that's William Peterson no
no no no no no no the redhaired guy oh
David Caruso CSI Miami get it right
David Caruso yeah uh him and and and guy
from the 18am right with the cigar oh
George papar I heard he's the biggest
dick really yeah you never heard that I
never heard that definitely heard that
firsthand I've heard it about David kuso
yeah yeah yeah I remember he said that
uh but I've heard it many times about
Wilford Brimley same since we were kids
I heard that really weird but wait what
yeah before even the internet hey don't
hire Wolford Brimley because nobody
cares that it's him you know he's is he
alive still well no I mean at the like
if you hear Wolford brimley's a dick I
see hire a different old guy wait who
else have we here were dicks I never I
mean I had heard William Peterson but I
don't I know if that's true oh Wilford
Brimley died in 2020 what he was that
old how old was it was recent I remember
I remember he must 100 years old I
remember I I cried for a
week look up how old he was he was uh
100 it got to be no he wasn't 100 n not
nobody's 100 90 something 86 that's it
that's crazy so he was one of those guys
terrible dude he's got the Morgan free
dude we were kids in those Quaker Oats
commercials he was like he was 30 but
had gra I mean he so old was 50 25 yeah
I have something to add to the thing I
don't like that people do right and a
lot of people do it and that is anytime
I think in movies you could get you
could probably guess what I'm going to
say in movies no just in if somebody
ever brings up Wilford Brimley
yeahhuh somebody around always has to
say yeah diabetes right oh yeah I forgot
about that's terrible I forgot about
that but that's terrible did he have
diabetes yeah but he did that and he
only he lived to be 86 he had diabetes
obviously diabetes doesn't matter yeah
diabetes huh what was the thing it was
like a that he said it like diabetes I
know it was for medicine yeah it was
exactly
diabetes why didn't he say diabetes man
well maybe that's how said it right it
should be diabetes it's that's a way
cooler word diabetes is cooler than
diabetes diabetes that's not cool
diabetes is sick thanks
Wilfred thank you wilf was he was he the
one what what was he from cocoon but now
he was from a show too though cocoon
he's on a show that was aired for a long
time did you guys know that the Netflix
intro that goes Gung you know what that
is no that's Kevin spy hitting his ring
in in the show House of Cards that sound
bite that part of the
Netflix come on it is that isn't that
weird H what do you mean but that's not
a sound of a ring dude I mean I I don't
know what to tell you that just is that
but that's not what a ring sounds like
in the show he goes with the ring on on
like a surface he
goes really and it's it's like basified
right but it's right right it's that
yeah let's play
it there you go see that's
it wow because that was their first Big
Show and then you know now it's it's
their logo bro that's crazy yeah you're
welcome you're welcome why does nobody
know that here's why here's why it's a
here's what everybody needs to do if
they haven't done it yet Kevin spy very
recently went on the tuo Carlson show
which doesn't exist anymore which is
just like on Twitter or X or whatever
because he got since he got fired Uh
Kevin spy went on Tucker Carlson's new
show as don't say as Frank Underwood and
Tucker Carlson played along 2024 has not
even begun yet and it does seem like
presidential race is effectively Frozen
in place if not over we know who the
candidates are it's too late for another
to get
in I know but is it too late there
anyone in this country 350 million
people who could jump this late date and
resc scramble the calculus of electoral
can you go to where he's on well there
may be someone in fact you already know
him you know his face and the question
is will he get in this cycle and that's
my question for
you well that's really a decision for
the people Tucker it's not something
that I really think about or want to
do and Merry Christmas to you too I mean
maybe we should do this luxury yeah
we'll talk about on luxury that is crazy
that is if there's ever been a reason to
sign up for
luxury we'll talk about it there yeah
all right dud that's it thanks for
listening sign up for Life shock dude
listen to his voice absolute shock why
would this is great that's really wild
it's so good spent a whole day
recovering from this okay I'm here with
Ace Ventura hello Tucker just [__]
it's Jim Carrey with a [__] Hawaiian
shirt on I mean all right also would
watch that oh my god dude my God all
right all right uh p.com Lifeline luxury
I'll see you soon Sacramento I'll see
you soon Phoenix I'll see you soon
Albuquerque and El Paso the private
record is coming out January
24th enjoy
it
I Fro I'm frozen I I froz
hello
hello hello